a final farewell for a brother
elvir was only 15 when he was killed in
this revenitza genocide in July 1995. so
was his father and two of his brothers
one is still missing
in 2011 only a few of Elvis remains were
found they were identified and we were
waiting until this year in the hope that
more would be found but they weren't and
we've decided to bury him now
saw her father 28 years ago
I lived the last time I saw my father
was on 8th July 1995. he came to visit
me this was the last time I saw him and
this is the first time I meet him again
since then to say goodbye
suffered has waited since 2011 to bury
some of the remains of his father his
hopes of finding the rest are fading
at least now I can come here to mourn
him it's a relief for me finally I know
where his remains are I will know where
he is buried
thousands of people attended this
commemorative funeral and helped bury
the victims many were found in Mars
Graves the Bosnian Serb Army and police
forces killed them after the fall of
strabremizza on 11 July 95 it took them
months to move their remains to other
sites in an attempt to hide the
atrocities
the international court of justice sent
the U.N Court in The Hague ruled that
what happened was a genocide but the
perpetrators and Bosnian sub-leaders
denied that
I'm burying my father today and they
keep saying it did not happen I feel
very sad about it this is very hard for
me
more than 8 300 people were killed in
this reveniza genocide in July 95. one
thousand are still missing
majority of people who were killed in
stradenitz a genocide in July in 1995
where men and boys however there were
dozens of women among them actually the
oldest victim of the genocide in
cerebrum was a woman who was 94 when she
was killed and this is the grave of the
youngest victim a baby girl named Fatima
who lived only a couple of hours after
she was born either had a mosage Al
Jazeera srebrenitza Eastern Bosnia and
Herzegovina